o dia 17 a visita de hu e sua filha
rafaela
estou aqui pra que isso até sobre a
filha catarina e do comércio local e
guiné porque só de israel ter feito isso
mas eu não pudesse olhar ao fim daqui a
11 anos na cedência cliente percebeu a
filha é um técnico muito carinho pela
minha falta fica é preciso que você faça
aquele sol e está dizendo área de metrô
se a mãe
ao navegar no meio disto novo mandato
mas tivemos aqui no ano passado e pedi
que dissesse isso porque no veículo há
uma semana depois pegando de respondeu
porque é a segunda passada eu cometo
criciúma papel de pão de cada dia
levando e tradição católica e de colégio
de freiras franciscanas de são josé onde
acredito que nós devemos amar os animais
ao mesmo tempo nas festas da igreja de
não era candidata
aos 10 anos de idade a derrotar as
galinhas não foi uma experiência sem
palavras
a contratação da equipe disse no eu que
me fazia fazer um pouco eu não vejo no
meu espírito urbano 30 anos necessita
primeiros anos da minha vida
estudem tude sobre o sabe mais sobre o
nosso tempero de amá los e fazer 2 o
filho um custo qual nenhum após aos
animais eram ensinados
informei filosofia exibiu questão
doutorado em filosofia clássica e
finalmente que meu pós-doutorado
já então quero sempre
é um misto de beja a guerra então porque
é que o leite ovos não tem árvores e
frutos do mar não ganhar com expectativa
o momento mágico com ações pacíficas
ao compreender o doutorado na noite de
verão primeira vez em contato com a
filosofia de ter sido o primeiro
defensor dos animais na década de 60 e
70 o brasil produzia no brasil os
estudos filosóficos médica falhou e
desde então isso ásia fazem estamos não
pode ter pesquisam sobre os habituais
eu parei de pesquisar sobre a
alimentação humana ao longo dos 3 20 os
milênios especialmente ao longo dos dois
últimos milênios
nós não tivemos sempre esperando que os
preços descessem à humanidade para parar
de fazer
todos os animais em um sentimento de
esperança porque desde 2000 anos
fizemos coisas muito erradas longa os
humanos
eu aproveito é enquanto não aprendemos a
respeitar os humanos não têm medo de
tocar na questão dos animais entre gado
com essa foi esse fato em que tudo fica
se arrastam porque estamos sempre
esperando além de discriminar os negros
só depois brasil foi bonita é teremos
então com ele e disponibilidade
espiritual e afetiva pegar os animais
cansei de esperar que o machismo você
vai entender nunca só então depois de
ter não precisar mais ter empurrado a
questão do terrorismo eu ia ser a quarta
pessoa o sangue mas cansei também sobre
a corrida do mundo e que só momento
entre os fiéis e um concreto não se
utilizar sem mais esquece de um terno é
que eu devia teria direito de começaram
a questionar fazemos aos animais
na verdade a neta discriminação prática
os pontos vamos nós de novo
durante a história chegou via racismo
machismo mas o que fazemos quando os
animais não humanos
nós não vemos
o homem até a década de 70 do século 20
quando se disse que esse setor de tânia
por se destacar na manhã de ontem a
fazer partos ter racismo machismo e o
tempo a dizer nada com sua discriminação
ponto os animais dão mãos
notamos ao retorno do evento
atualmente 70 milhões de animais
nossa 7 bilhões de anos
é preciso que se diga que esses 70
milhões de animais mortos para consumo
humano ao redor do planeta
servem aquela tv e 23 e 15 11 permite o
trânsito
mesmo tendo uma média de 30 animais
foram mortos
é tanta que muitos brasileiros e nunca
vida e jamais ver o carro nem toquei
disse em seus quadros fazendo cessar os
animais porque jogos em gramados nos
últimos 50 anos pelo papel do peti sinal
mantenho a animação disse anos eu cresci
o entanto que é necessário no momento
300 gramas de proteína animal e se
dedicar na década de 60 e 70 é pecado de
300 gramas por dia
os ensaios para desenvolver o corpo e
dor nos tecidos deles hoje psico de rua
a propagandear a proteína de origem
animal a dior simples jogos com a mesma
desculpa furada
nós não precisamos de afirmar-se dos
analisados na cabeça e teve um sabor que
testemunha essa necessidade é a primeira
geração de ganso no mundo somos hoje
milhões ao redor do planeta que diz
assinaram o cotão tarde é da época de
mal usada
nós sugerimos nenhum tipo de carro em
branco entender-me nos direitos
declarados de animais dessas carnes nos
direitos leite sai mais rápido nos
dentes de castanhas ao ver os avanços
velha não esteve nos povos nem qualquer
o duto industrializado que não tem em
seus ingredientes mais quer de novos
animais mas a decisão ética bonita
própria biografia
a matança de animais não se repetiu não
sou grato
nós abolimos do nosso vai estar pronta
todas as peças fabricadas em poucos
pedras lamas esquecer porque todas essas
merdas gostou e meu futuro
o tormento ea morte dos animais bonitos
da nossa diversão você espetáculos com
animais cavalgamos cavalhadas aqueles
jogos sorteios e faz doer filhas ideal
pra isso
abolimos a visita ao sol a fazer os
aparelhos porque esses animais jamais
comitê com o clipe e 17 a condenação da
prisão perpétua
a mulher que o socorro médico e testados
nos olhos defeitos e erros na pedra fada
que a ferida de diversas espécies de
animais e tentamos para que aquele
selecção seja bonita nos testes de
medicamentos e produtos químicos e
doenças de pele
essa proposta polícia está pegando
não é uma proposta tal dieta no sentido
claudino o português que se dedica há
certa discrição aquilo que se conclui
atualemnte gestor a mulher que essa
prática é essa
porque se ontem à discriminação
praticamos outros direitos fundamentais
dos animais interesses fundamentais
vezes mas sempre nos resta uma pergunta
por que escreveram seus animais
determinamos os animais e levou mesmo a
razão pela qual descrevemos os negros os
índios soubesse os homossexuais estão
sexuais pela qual nós terminamos os
estrangeiros pela forma discriminando os
débitos
os idosos não sentimos um imenso a voz
de ter consciência da nossa pequenez e
porque sabemos que se você entender a 13
a morte do de navais ao universo físico
ao conversão
nós temos necessidade de construir nossa
mente uma forma de nos proteger dias
daquilo que nos torna pequenos alvo mais
fácil de fazer desvio é pisar naqueles
que é o nosso retorno neste planeta
estão todos federal mas nós criamos de
depoimento da nossa riqueza da nossa
filha
nossa vulnerabilidade e até de capinação
é um continua contra os negros contra os
índios contra os homossexuais para os 26
mais outros fiéis de outros credos
contra as mulheres e contra os animais
a grande pergunta que sempre eles fazem
é com vocês o que tenha sido o tênis que
os médicos em ter filho e os
nutricionistas formados nas faltas
adicional que não é possível determinar
a não ser de origem animal
entretanto quando então vamos completar
se explicar alguma proteína um pedaço do
que derrotar de novo somos primeira
divisão do concelho
ele tocou em uma fábrica inteira
não existe isso porque o corpo não faz
ser cientes dê certo aqui nascidos até
falou na cabeça o tempo dos 20 que no
nosso caso precisamos falar é que
façamos nosso terceiro toda a ponteira
que encontramos nos produtos atualizados
que é uma proteína que foi tal devolver
o animal nos campos cereais e tantas
dizer lhes que são os da carne porque se
não passaria dos fundos
cada um dos inscritos precisamos do
leite porque senão ficaria dos
desnutridos e tentado decapitar se
hectares de grãos cereais e todas
cultivados neste momento de 70 a 90 são
destinados à de gestão todos os animais
tentam por cento das áreas mais férteis
do planeta somos alvos para o contido de
vê-los cereais foi está alta tecnologia
e emicida e de todas a proteína vegetal
são mais 100 possível é ter desperdiçado
e procon metabolismo
todo animal enquanto governos a carne
bovina nós encontramos ela apenas quatro
gramas para cada centro no trânsito
tenta vegetal gênio que eles descobriram
que quando comemos a carta de um pouco
as encontramos volta 12 gramas de toda a
proteína da de significado e também
natal quando começa a carta geotécnica
ao funk através do itueto que compõem a
ração
ontem nas quais não temos de volta
apenas 17% das 17 horas quando estou bem
diferente temos a faca início das
atividades será de cada 100 gramas de
proteína no leite declarou que apenas 22
gramas de proteína e parece alguém assim
precisamos para coleta de ovos
nós não sentamos e do dem e um ser vivo
com apenas 23 anos
portanto não é verdade que precisamos
aproveitar um mau tempo se proteger
porque é base totalidade da proteína ou
produzido no planeta que poderia ser
produzida e motivada para tentarmos os
apenas 72 mil anos
imagina a quantidade de dor e sofrimento
que se vai passar no congresso em 2006 e
do estudo e da reunião foi para discutir
que finaliza a questão não precisam mais
ser dotado de sensibilidade eficiência
com nosso povo deu ao final da conversa
os cientistas fizeram uma declaração
pública de que não há diferença e nós
sentimos que vai ser a única diferença é
que eles não cobrem e se necessário a
sua dor em seu favor
a imagem seguinte portanto que os
filósofos a gnosis a 40 e 50 anos prega
que é o momento de fazermos a final da
médica alvo no seu relatório de 2010 e
março de 2010 ao médico receber um curso
de saúde nutrição de tudo da vida no
planeta de que não haverá venda do
planeta se seguirmos aberta de uma visão
ou mais árvores para serem levadas mais
firmes para ligar fundações e drama dos
animais não é mais só onde jogaram a
quantidade de escreventes de 7 milhões
de animais
os consultores da onu que não são
pequenos e defensores dos animais
afirmam explicitamente no texto só irá à
venda do planeta daqui a 30 ou sociedade
se fundir o movimento se nos tornarmos
ficamos estamos aqui tá bom convocado e
convidar todos para pensar sobre essa
questão